[Music]
mr. stork it smells like a new car in
here
man Tom's my friend and I was I was
contemplating helping him in the future
with his suit and stuff and just we were
just going back and forth but I think I
would win now tell it to go the entire
suit hey everybody its charlie huge news
we just found out about spider-man's new
costume that he's gonna get going
through Avengers 4 in spider-man
homecoming to remember spider-man 2 is
gonna pick up immediately after the
events of Avengers 4 so obviously
spider-man's gonna have to come back
during Avengers 4 we all expect him to
come back mr. stark I don't want to go
so in addition to Letitia right talking
about her and Tom Holland on the set of
Avengers 4 talking about upgrading his
suit the person who in real life designs
all the Marvel costumes and makes them
was also talking about the next new
costume after the iron spider costume so
we got to break this down if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video so we'll start
with what the costume designer said in
real life confirming new costume then
I'll talk about surety and spider-man
within the world of the Avengers this
sort of explains how they might go about
doing that so the costume designers
named Lewis frog Lee she said Marvel
research very thoroughly they were very
clear about the decision and decided it
should go back to being pretty simple as
a young guy he had this homemade suit
then he has this beautiful suit that
Tony Stark gives him so that's the
original stark tech suit not the iron
spider one that he got during infinity
war but then she goes on when asked
about spider-man homecoming 2 that
costume will have to have big changes
because in the film spider-man becomes
more like a man not a teenager
so obviously across these films
spider-man's getting older and even
though a whole lot of time isn't gonna
be passing between infinity war and when
he comes back remember there's a
time-travel element in play so even if
there is a time jump at the beginning of
Avengers 4 I think when they fix
everything the timeline will sort of
Reese
said and everything will feel normal it
will almost feel like he's barely been
gone so Tony Stark the Avengers put
everything back in its place so that not
everybody on the planet Earth knows that
half of them were erased just a little
while ago that being said most of the
Avengers and the people that survived
into phase four will probably remember
what happened so not only will Spider
Man age physically because a little time
will have gone by but they're also
saying that he's aging emotionally like
pretty much no brainer you go through an
experience like that it's going to age
you up pretty quickly so without
speculating too much about what might
happen to Tony Stark what's been
happening lately is that he's relied on
Iron Man for guidance like mr. stark I
just want to help so he does what Iron
Man tells him to do previously on Peters
from this instead you hacked a
multimillion-dollar suit so you could
sneak around behind my back doing the
one thing I told you not to do is
everyone okay no thanks to you he has
skills he rebels he tries to be a hero
on his own it usually goes sideways but
then he figures things out but now going
into phase four he's actually gonna have
to learn to be the person that calls the
shots then even further down the road
when he gets a little bit older he'll
probably mentor someone else in another
Avengers from like Avengers five or
something like that
so it makes sense that if he's gonna be
going back to basics he'll have a bigger
hand in designing his next suit the one
that they're talking about in this
interview there's a little bit of
footage that people are thinking might
be promo for the new suit because this
was done for the parks so it's a
slightly different version of the
costume than the one that he wore during
spider-man homecoming but it looks very
similar but I am super to clean
technology and she adds that
nobody cool stuff from what you are
serving yet so if you can't tell the
difference between these two suits the
symbol on the back is very different in
the symbol on his chest is also much
much larger those cosmetic changes aside
the coloring looks pretty similar to
spider-man homecoming although the Blues
on this were pretty light so they might
tune that down just a little bit just
imagine them going back towards a more
classic spider-man design with the
technology that they've gained the last
couple of movies which is we're sure he
comes in so Leticia Wright is saying oh
me and Tom were on set talking about me
helping him out with his suit so what
does sure he do that Iron Man doesn't do
because they both have the
nanotechnology in the black panther suit
and the new Iron Man bleeding-edge armor
and in the new iron spider armor so
they're already doing a lot of the same
things but I think what Sheree brings to
the table is a more organic traditional
sense of style and obviously part of
what she's implying is is that Peter
will have input into what his new suit
looks like so he can say I want it to
look something like this
and she can help fabricated unlimited
range also it cooked with audio
surveillance system check these up
remote access camera beats updated to
interface directly with my same table
there was a lot of discussion about who
the smartest person in the MCU is that's
not super important for this the big
difference between Sheree and Iron Man
is as the tradition is a much more
important part of her life in the way
that she thinks about things than an
Iron Man's thought process
he's the futurist that was part of the
line that Hawkeye used to make fun of
him at the end of civil war now the
whole idea of the Black Panther movie is
that there's this war between tradition
and looking to the future
so surety and T'Challa are just a much
better balance of those two things so I
think that's where you get back to the
more traditional comic book spider-man
costume is is in her thought process the
thing about the iron spider armor is
that it looks more like a stark suit
that just colored to look like a
spider-man suit it's genuinely built for
battle so it feels just way more
hardcore than a normal spider-man
friendly neighborhood spider-man that he
calls himself would go so imagine him
going back to a version of the costume
that works
little bit more like the Black Panther
costume looks less like armor but still
does all the same stuff that the iron
spider costume did from a practical
standpoint yeah they want to sell action
figures so every new costume that they
put spider-man in is another action
figure that they can sell so from a
business perspective that's the reason
why he's in a new costume every single
suit so I think that he'll always have
this iron spider Avengers costume he can
always go back to it but it'll just sit
there on a shelf until they eventually
get to Secret Wars or some crazy big
Avengers x-men crossover where he needs
a genuine suit of armor a lot of you are
asking about symbiote I think the
closest they'll get to that in the
future is just building in multiple
different modes to the one suit that he
ends up wearing during spider-man two
like a stealth mode for instance that's
one thing we haven't done yet although
they did sell an action figure for
spider-man homecoming that did have a
stealth mode so maybe that was just an
idea that they cut out of the film
because they felt like they didn't need
the scene so let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with his
next costume and remember they're gonna
be shooting that movie this summer so we
will see what the costume looks like
within the next couple of months
so what's gonna happen is is there'll be
new Marvel later this week just leave
all your requests in the comments below
there was a whole bunch of behind the
scenes infinity war clips that drop so
if you guys want me to post that just
let me know in the comments but click
here for more Avengers 4 and click here
for that teaser breakdown thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]